pues bien para seguir reforzando este
concepto que parece ser un poco difícil
pero realmente no lo es tanto
voy a actualizar la siguiente expresión
-12 s cuadrada menos 38 efe más 22 antes
de que nos aboquemos y factor hicimos
esto por agrupación es que tenemos un
factor común tenemos como factor común
12 y de hecho voy a actualizar un menos
dos porque lo que voy a buscar es que
este primer coeficiente que este lado de
la f cuadrada sea positivo
entonces me quedan menos 2 que
multiplica a 6
efe cuadrada y después menos 38 efe
entre menos 2 me va a dar más 19 efe y
después más 22 entre menos 2 me da menos
11 más entre menos me da menos y 22
entre 2 me da 11 perfecto y ahora me voy
a fijar en la expresión que tengo aquí
adentro ya no tiene el factor común
entonces ahora sí piensan factorizar la
por agrupación recuerda que si tenemos
al lado de la f cuadrada algo que no es
un 1 entonces lo mejor o lo más fácil es
intentar factorizar lo por agrupación
así que voy a multiplicar 6 x menos 11
para buscar dos números que me den de
resulta
esto acuerde me tienen que dar 6 x menos
11 6 x menos 11 que es 66 y ya más ve
los mismos los números me tienen que dar
suma 2 19
además b es igual a 19 perfecto dos
números que multiplicados menos 66 y
sumados media 19 se me ocurre pensar en
a ver qué pasa si el 66 del vídeo entre
33 me da a 22 22 y 322 y 3 me funcionan
fíjate bien si yo tomo 22 positivo y 3
negativo me va a quedar 22 x menos 3 me
da menos 66 y 22 más menos 3 esto es lo
mismo que 19 positivo allí está 22 y
menos tres son los dos números que me
funcionan y son los dos números que
cumplen estas dos ecuaciones al mismo
tiempo y bueno ya que encontré los los
números que hacemos bueno lo que voy a
hacer con estos dos números es romper
esta expresión que tengo aquí adentro
del paréntesis y en lugar de poner 19
efe voy a poner 22 efe - 3
efe pero ten cuidado voy a poner menos 3
efe primero y después el 22
efe que por cierto no olvides que esto
me da
y 9 f de resultado es decir estoy
haciendo lo mismo y aquí al lado me
quedan 6 f cuadrada y menos 11 y lo
estoy poniendo así porque fíjate bien
que 22 efe tiene mucho más parecido a
menos 11 que lo que lo tiene al menos
tres y menos tres tiene mucho más
parecido al 6 que lo que tiene el 22 por
lo tanto me funciona mejor ponerlo así 6
y 3 tienen como factor común a un 3 y 22
y 11 tienen como factor común a un 11
por lo tanto esto me va a poder ayudar a
factorizar esta expresión de una manera
mucho más sencilla y ojo no olvides este
menos 2 entonces todo esto por menos 2
que no hay que olvidar muy bien ahora me
voy a fijar en lo de adentro y para
factorizar por agrupación me fijo en el
primer grupo de mis primeros dos
términos y de aquí voy a factorizar lo
más que se pueda y ya que factor hice lo
más que se pueda ahora méxico en el
siguiente grupo ahora voy a fijar en los
siguientes dos voy a tomar a otro color
que sea distinto voy a tomar este color
de aquí un morado para mi segundo grupo
y de este segundo grupo voy a factorizar
lo más que se pueda también entonces de
efe cuadrada y menos 3 efe lo más que se
puede esos menos
efe - 3 efe que multiplica a menos 2
efe y después multiplica esperen es que
bueno puede ser menos 3 cf es una buena
opción pero también lo podemos poner
positivo y mejor quitarnos de todo este
problema entonces en lugar de poner
menos 3
efe voy a poner 3 efe positivo 3
efe que multiplica a bueno primero a 2
fm 12 efe por 3 de enfermedad 6 efe
cuadrada y después a menos 1 - 1 por 13
enfermedad menos 3
efe este de aquí es lo mismo que estoy
acá y bueno ahora me voy a fijar en la
parte de morado en la parte de morado mi
factor común es 11 11 que multiplicar
bueno en primer lugar a 12 efe y después
al menos 111 por 2 enfermedad 22
efe y 11 por menos 1 me da menos 11 y
ojo no olvides poner este menos 2 este
menos 2 es importantísimo para no
equivocarnos y ahora de todo esto que
tengo aquí me fijo que tengo 2s menos 1
como factor común tengo aquí dos suman 2
y estos dos suman dos cada uno de ellos
está multiplicado por 12 efe - 1
12 efe - 1 es mi factor común y lo puedo
sacar aquí 12 efe - 1 que multiplica
quien bueno en primer lugar de este
primer grupo me va a multiplicar a 13
efe y de este segundo grupo me va a
multiplicar a 11 a 11 y es más déjame
poner el 11 con el mismo color de morado
y la misma tonalidad más 11 + 11 morado
más 11 perfecto entonces lo que hago es
fijarme en este factor común o dicho de
otra manera lo que estoy haciendo buscar
la distributiva edad de la que hemos
hablado varias veces al revés
estoy pensando como una distributiva y
dada al revés y ojo no olvides este
menos 2 que es muy importante y que lo
voy a poner del mismo color y entonces
ya tengo la factorización de esta
expresión la factorización de menos 12
efe cuadrada menos 38 efe más 22 es
menos 2 que multiplica a 12 efe - 1 que
a su vez multiplica a 3 fm 11